Today, all that is changing rapidly as the number
of health related open APIs and web tools explodes.
Of these, the most important is
fast health care interoperability resources or FHIR spelled
F-H-I-R. FHIR is a new standard based on
contemporary technologies and it's achieving dramatic acceptance and adoption.
FHIR offers the promise of open access to clinical data,
with the right permissions of course.
As you can see from these examples,
it is even turning electronic medical records systems into open app platforms,
similar to the smartphone in your pocket.
This is the first university level course based upon FHIR.
As we proceed, you will literally be working to help solve
real world health care challenges using the health informatics approaches of the future.
We'll now travel to Emory Health Systems,
EICU to look at an example of that from an earlier iteration of the course.